anyway it's not true now but especially
in some regions especially in some
higher magnification we see a lot of
that Morocco is in the Crimea in the
Crimea we've got about 120 to 130 and
Joseph del Mobile canyons are made with
no links to the international sponsors
again one and two on other hand you have
a lot of voluntary based organizations
and some and some and organization look
for the health partners should not just
on the polish side of together from the
public service to reduce the pollution
do to get them from the international
resources
and I didn't really had a very clear
picture of how the NGOs movie began
there could it be we'll have more on the
intellectual level that the beginnings
were formed on whether the grassroots
and luckily for one and then in Ukraine
was apparel or was a different and for
mr. was neck you claim that the United
States actually prefers to see Ukraine
as the buffer zone rather than to have
siding with Russia or with Europe their
art is this sofa can you have spent this
have more arguments to this day we are
talking about something that for 2011's
organization in Poland and this is the
row number that mean this is the right
number which excludes many kind of
organization which can be counted as a
part of the third sector life fantage
associations are not visit in this in
this number the majority of the foreign
government organization these are
grassroots level organizations about
fifty-five percent of them do not have
any permanent staff face do not the page
stop the same moment we have 200 well
established in geo since I can give the
example which are working internally or
abroad I can give the example polish
manager an organization has the mission
in Afghanistan and build the school in
Afghanistan these
eating thousands house of people of
students of children in Poland when the
head quake in van was two months ago
they came with the with the hell with
the charity in a week after the pathway
that means letting that is both their
house the majority is the grassroots
level offenses and a lot of this
grassroots level organization active in
the international club emo people are
very small ones even if that means that
they are not invite invite to teachers
go home or move on
from not Vilna to participate in some
activities in the school that they sell
to stick the listen to students that but
no immediate reference level in Ukraine
the tradition of non-government
organization was stopped by the Soviet
times you have to understand that until
you have to remember that they are some
NGOs which mutual base which we use the
fundament like tourists forever blind
society the non-government organization
which expands into many daily activities
people from the client societal involved
in establishing the vast difference how
to the were involved in establishing
some newspapers and many many local
mission but the Commission the memo
remember about the